what I want to do in this video is
explore the mechanics of a typical
adjustable rate mortgage often known as
an arm and then think about you know
under what situations could this be
advantageous and in which situations
might not this be the best scenario for
the homebuyer so let's just first think
about the more.the let's think about the
mechanics and to do that I will draw a
little bit of a timeline so let's say on
this axis right over here and the
horizontal axis or so I have the
vertical axis this is going to be your
rate your interest rate and this is in
percentage terms so maybe that's 1
percent 2 percent 3 percent 4 5 6 and it
can go higher than that even and here
let's this lets say this is the time
axis this right over here is the time
axis in years so time and years and so
that is one year two years three years
four years whoops I mean to do that four
years five years and maybe we'll go six
years out so before I even plot the
adjustable rate mortgage let's think
about a fixed rate mortgage so if I had
a fixed rate mortgage it is exactly what
the word implies the rate is going to be
fixed so on a fixed rate mortgage maybe
where the fixed rate mortgages are at
the time you get the loan based on your
based on the type of loan you're getting
and and your credit score let's say you
get a 4% fixed rate so that means over
the life of your loan your loan is going
to be at a four percent so whatever
whatever you have to pay on your print
whatever principle you have left over
every period you will pay an equivalent
of a four percent annual rate and we've
gone into some depth in that in other
videos where we talk about 30 year and
15 year and 10 year fixed mortgages and
you might be saying wait I thought I I
thought as time goes on I pay down more
and more principle which means that each
of my payments more less and less of it
goes to interest so
doesn't feel like my interest is
changing and there's truth to that the
dollar amount that you're paying towards
interest with a traditional fixed-rate
mortgage does go down every month as you
pay down more and more principal but the
interest rate the rate that you're
paying on the principal that you have
remaining is going to be constant and in
this example it would be a constant four
percent now what about an adjustable
rate mortgage well as you can imagine
that means that the mortgage is going to
adjust so an adjustable rate mortgage
might start at two percent and that
night look really good but the way that
the deal will work is well if under if
short-term interest rates were to
increase the adjustable rate mortgage
will increase as well so there could be
a reality where if short-term interest
rates increase enough the adjustable
rate mortgage interest rate or rate
might be even higher than the fixed rate
mortgage and if interest rates were to
go dramatically higher then depends if
there are caps in place and whatever
else this rate could grow dramatically
higher what do I mean by all of that and
what do I mean by what if short-term
interest rates were to go up well when
you have an adjustable rate mortgage
it's usually it usually adjusts to some
index rate and in the u.s. the most
typical one is short-term Treasuries
that's the rate at which the government
has to pay when the government wants to
borrow money for a year so one year
Treasuries although there could be other
underlying in indices another very
typical index for any type of adjustable
rate loan not just mortgages but any
type of loans even corporate loans could
be the London interbank offer rate LIBOR
London interbank offer rate and we have
other videos on what LIBOR is but let's
just say that we're dealing with one
year Treasuries is the underlying index
and one year Treasuries there's a market
for Treasuries and so that just changes
with the day so let's say this is the
plot of what what happens for one year
one year Treasuries over one year
Treasuries over time so this is the rate
so this means that you know right at
this time period of time that if you
were to lend the
and money for a year you're going to get
2% the government's borrowing rate is 2%
now it's very unlikely that any lender
will give you the exact same rate as the
government the government can print
money you're The Full Faith and Credit
of the United States so you don't have
that when you're paying you know you you
might get into financial difficulty you
might not be able to pay your loan for
some reason and so you're not going to
get that exact rate you're going to get
that rate plus some premium and so let's
say you have pretty good credit so let's
say the premium is only 1% and a premium
like 1% that's actually what even you
know very very well-established
companies and things would get so this
is just to make the math easy so let's
say and you see that right over here at
the time that the loan was issued the
the 1-year Treasury rate was like 1% and
so you're going to get a 2% and the way
that an arm works is at some periods
sometimes it'll be every six months some
times every year your rate will be reset
so let's say we're dealing with a an
adjustable rate mortgage and it resets
every year so yearly yearly yearly
adjustment yearly adjustment and the
case that we're looking at so that means
you're going to pay that your 2% for the
first year from 0 from time 0 to 1 year
going by and then at that point they're
going to look at what the underlying
index is and secondly the index now
looks like it's at about one point six
percent so you're going to pay a 1%
premium over that so you're going to pay
two point six percent so you're going to
pay two point six percent for the next
year you're going to pay two point six
for the percent for the next year
now short-term interest rates have gone
even more gone up even more looks like
they're pretty close to three so now
you're going to pay 4% interest so in
this scenario where interest rates have
steadily gone up your mortgage rate is
is justing every year up and you see by
at least this the third year by this
third year you are paying roughly the
same as if you had gotten a fixed-rate
mortgage now you might be saying hey but
it still been a good deal I've paid for
the first two years I paid lower than I
would have paid on the fixed-rate
mortgage and not only the third year I'm
I'm paying the same and that's true for
this scenario that so far has worked out
pretty well for you but then in year
three interest rates are even higher so
it would adjust even higher so it might
go it might do so your adjustable rate
might be up here and so in this year
you're actually paying more your
interest rate the rate of interest on
the principal that you owe on your house
has now is now more than your fixed-rate
mortgage and then I draw a scenario
where all of a sudden becomes more
favorable again and so it might adjust
down so here you're still paying more
than you would pay in your fixed rate
but then by this year maybe right over
here you're now paying less again and
this is just one of many scenarios so in
this one you look okay you know
adjustable rate mortgage maybe you know
this might worked out more years and not
I'm I'm paying less than I would have
paid with the fixed rate mortgage lower
rate I should say there's only a couple
of years here but you have to remember
this is only just one of any of many
possible scenarios maybe inflation goes
crazy and or whatever else and maybe
this index does something like this
which isn't typical it's not like it
happens that that's likely to happen but
things like that have happened in
history when you had a large
inflationary periods and in something
like this all of a sudden you could see
your adjustable rate mortgage adjusting
up by a good bit now there's often these
things called caps in place that keep
the mortgage from adjusting more than a
percent or two percent per year but if
you saw something like if you saw
something like that or if you saw if you
saw something that just went straight
like this that means that over the life
of your loan especially if your loan
goes out ten or fifteen or thirty years
you could end up paying a substantial
amount more interest now on the other
hand it's completely possible that
interest rates do this that interest
rates do this the entire time in which
case the adjustable rate mortgage might
work out better so you might be noticing
a pattern here with your fixed-rate
mortgage it's very predictable this is
very predictable where you can predict
this so a payment that you're making
from one month and even if it's interest
only whatever payment you're making
whatever interest rate it is not going
to
age while the adjustable-rate mortgage
it is less predictable it is less
predictable less predictable and this
brings up a very interesting idea called
interest rate risk which you might
sometimes hear people talk about on the
on the cable finance networks in
whatever else or if you're reading the
financial section of the newspaper
interest rate risk and this is just the
risk that you take on if interest rates
were to change dramatically so if you
have if you have an adjustable rate
mortgage what's your risk well the
interest rate risk you're taking on is
well what if interest goes up a lot then
your payment goes up now with the
fixed-rate mortgage who takes on the
interest rate risk well with a fixed
rate mortgage the bank takes on the
interest rate risk so let's let's so and
the so let me write this down so this is
an arm arm and then and then this right
over here is the fixed fixed rate whoops
let me write a little bit clearer this
right over here is fixed rate and so who
takes on the interest rate risk in the
arm scenario well the bot the borrower
does they might get the benefit of lower
rates but if rates were to go up
dramatically the borrower takes on this
risk the borrower borrower takes on this
risk while in the fixed rate who takes
on the risk well in this scenario it's
going to be the lender it's going to be
the lender why is a lender taking on a
risk well if they lend something to you
at a fixed interest rate let's say this
4% and if interest were to go up
dramatically remember many lenders
especially financial institutions like
banks they are borrowing money as well
who are they borrowing money from well
they could be borrowing from a whole
bunch of sources but one of them as the
people who are keeping deposits remember
what a bank does so if this is the bank
right over here
people give deposits and we go into much
more detail in other videos and then it
is loaned and then it is loaned out
so when they take deposits they are
usually they're oftentimes promising
people interest and when they get loans
when they issue loans they're getting
interest as well now if this is fixed
right over here
but if interest rates short-term
interest rates were to go up if this
were to go up then they're going to be
paying more than they're getting or this
is not changing while this is going up
so they're not going to be making as
much money so the risk adjustable rate
mortgage borrower takes on the fixed
rate the lender takes on